if I knew that I'd go out and direct it
the wonderful thing about theatre as an
art form is that it's it's a purely
empirical art form it's all about what
works and every show every production is
created anew right from the moment that
you go on in the rehearsal hall so I
wouldn't sit here and say to you I'd
like to see a hamlet in which I don't
know and which Hamlet is you know a
dragon but I'm just riffing here I
wouldn't think of it in conceptual terms
what i want though is to go to the
theater and see something that i'm not
expecting to see and that doesn't mean
that it has to be transgressive it
doesn't mean that it has to be unusual
it could just be perfect it's actually
now more common to see conceptual
productions of Shakespeare in which
Hamlet is played as a Nazi or a
homosexual or you know I mean whatever
concept is being laid over the play than
it is to see a production of Shakespeare
in which there is no conceptual overlay
and the play is simply being presented
on its own terms this is something I've
been noticing and writing about actually
in the last year or so that that
conceptual theatre is now the new normal
it's the thing that we rebel against and
so now I'm really surprised to see a
production that doesn't have this kind
of overlay and I might add that the
Hamline Broadway be Jude Law really
doesn't have an overlay at all not like
say the the Macbeth with Patrick Stewart
that was done last season in which it's
it's set in some place more or less like
soviet russia the problem with the Jude
Law Hamlet was simply that it wasn't
predictable that it was a very down the
center modern production I mean we
sometimes forget that we we live in
modernity and therefore modernism is
normal you wouldn't go to the theatre
expecting to see an old fashioned Hamlet
where everybody wears old-fashioned
costumes you don't get points to me now
for putting on a hamlet where everybody
dresses in black I've seen that one I've
seen that one several times
but again it's not that it has to be new
it's simply that it has to be different
fresh that it doesn't bore that it
doesn't make me I don't feel as I'm
watching it that I know where it's going
to go I want to be surprised especially
by a familiar play
well if I ever see another Shakespeare
production where somebody drives a jeep
on stage I'm going to run screaming up
the aisle these tend to be matters of
design I mean we're seeing a lot of it's
very common to see Shakespeare with
automatic weapons you know things like
that they are cliches their new clichés
but they are cliches and their
provincial you know I it's not clever to
do Henry 5 and have everybody dressed in
United Nations soldiers costumes anymore
seen that one too that kind of thing
irritates me I really get irritated when
a classic play is hijacked for political
purposes where somebody has some sort of
political agenda that they want to use
the play to advance which again is
fairly common with Shakespeare but the
wonderful thing about theatre is that
anything no matter how to dentists no
matter how stupid it sounds at first
glance can be made to work if it is
charged with freshness and originality
you can have an entirely political
Shakespeare production and I'll be
sitting on the edge of my seat as long
as it's surprising as long as it's not
just the standard out of the box a
pseudo transgressive production that we
just see too much up nowadays